[Music]
beautiful history books will tell you the
roman empire dirt in the fit century see
what this would come so great surprised
to the millions of people who built in
the roman empire middle ages
this medieval roman empire with muse
refer to today is the  bus and 10 and a
week and in three girl i see i got one
constantine the first question emperor
must the cable or the rome and park we
news in gold constantinople
music end of the site of the ancient
greek series the his soul of the busy
cuffs set room in fort en
and the empires western province is what
conquered by barbarians constantine east
river of commune seat about to an
emperor's
their generations of mflor floors for
the next eleventh century
sharon continuous we die with the classic
roman empire game de bus en 10  empire
and technological in sochi ties
laces over the neighbors to these ten
skins previously
barbarians in the name sentry visitors
of gyan the frontier for rectory
setting graceful  stone ears and downs
of imperial palace in constantinople
on hair of gold' alliance flight of the
imperial woman of it new york in must
mix lions for a guest
arrow other news gordon burns sam van
a new building golden tree medieval room
and engineers ide news hydraulic
engines  tour once that implies a pure logo
hi other in here this aspects
of a chat room and culture to be seen
in and brothers koolweg of traditional
military car2go island in the fever
which continues romina working class b
are ten species also ensure you
realize study in showroom  and
counterparts many forms offline
specific tree surgeon ceramics leather
operation vision leaving for manufacturing
silk
but of course the bus in 10 empire
dimchev fest' annelore our ranger woman
terrorist innovate creating vest
museums en ornate marble cards
the architect constructing number is
church's one of which kon  ayasofya he
death so high
msn to be went to the shane van have the
empire was  al zo home to great
intellectuals
towns electroni he is imperial
princess in the 12 century and dedicated
to live the philosophy and history to
recount over fathers frame is historians
foremost provides vision team
political history at the time of the
first kuzee
can be different color leo de  mathematician
inventory system or beacons
that kill a target to the empire what fast
greece and turkey scratching cm
handshake lammers
this system all out the edge of the
empire tony and brother or division arms
with in one hour or separation then with the
words that there is a green  screen
protector the empire forever in 1203 and
army of french and venetian crusaders mee
the deal with a takes alexios and
glass
alexia like the sauna postmarked
and promised to crusaders boss regions
and support to help him louis take their
own van is only
alexia succeeded  we after i hear the
population who is calling and the lexie yancham
itself was the post and kilt
so alexios is to yellow or green para  graph
embarrassing constantinople
parts massive fire switch to sprinkle
paul workshop in gent and evil eye
catcher who caught about one third of the
population homeless the series was three
little tip who slade here at the
roman emperor michael polio bait per
is disturbed empire never be one  waiter
territory the crusaders got cancer
finally in 1450 three arms and for with
my the cancer captured constantinople
bringing up inclusive and till the roman
empire
despite the arms conquest many greek
speaking inherent of the eastern
mediterranean continue to call
themselves 2012 polyphony first century
info
it was  a dozen the renaissance that
the tour is in ten empire
was decorated for western european
the renaissance was about reconnecting
with the wisdom of a theory and since
the distance of family for roman
empire
suggestion that european shoe neverlost
arguments great western european switch
a tissue paper lines  between the ages
to whether the sting west classica  l
what a speaking
a roman empire of the mini vogue speak
english a roman empire scholars ri
take the letter group
these teams and die won hundred years
after the dead fall the this 10 empire
was born when more database and 10
church mentioned in this video
check out  this lesson and learn how
ayasofya
playing empires has multiple regions and
the sun and decorated with boffin's and
three collins and de [ __ ] roelens
[Music]